AMBER WEINBERG: Hello,
everybody.
Can you hear me?
All right.
Was lunch great?
Lunch was great, huh?
So in this panel we
will be talking
about responsive layout.
And George Crawford
is our opener.
He is the Lead Developer of The
Economist's HTML5 project
and the maintainer of FT
Columnflow, which is this
really cool magazine-like thing
that I hope he will
explain to all of us.
Then we have Razvan.
He works on CSS Regions, CSS
Exclusions, and other ways of
improving digital publishing
on the web.
Then we have Andy over here.
He was formerly the Lead
Engineer on Bing maps and then
worked for the awesome Clearleft
offices in Brighton.
And currently, he does the
client-side work at Guardian.
So George, if you want to come
up and give your presentation.
GEORGE CRAWFORD: So responsive
design is a bit of a buzzword.
I'm sure you're all familiar
with it, but it sort of lacks
definition.
First slide is coming up.
So responsive design,
it lacks definition.
We need some clarity.
I'm sure you've all thought
from time to time about
various considerations we need
to take in mind when thinking
about responsive development.
I liked a quote on
Andy's blog--
"Responsiveness is what a
website does when it's loaded
into an unknown browser on an
unknown device by an unknown
individual." So websites need
to respond to the device and
the environment and to the user
and to many other factors
to offer the best experience.
But dealing with all of these
considerations is far too
broad for this session, so we're
just going to talk about
responsive layout.
So here's a typical example of
a site that really thinks
about responsive layout
that's only really
based on viewport width.
This is something I stole from
Amber's blog posts, the United
Pixelworkers.
Yeah, it's funky, and it's
a really nice sort of
interactive experience.
And that doesn't really answer
all of the questions that we
need to answer.
So we don't need to just
consider the aesthetics of a
layout but also the whole
effect on the reading
experience and the way that
a user will [INAUDIBLE]
the sites.
Like, if we need to do extra
processing to achieve a better
layout, we might need to wait
longer for the network, we
might need to wait for the CPU,
we might decrease the
frame weight.
So following the discussion we
had earlier in the network
panel, we need to consider
things like this.
With the Economist web app that
I've been working on, our
first page load, we just use
real links to real images.
But as the user navigates to
an addition, subsequent
articles, we download
with Ajax requests.
And we actually send the
dimensions of the viewports in
the request, so that images can
be dynamically re-sized on
the server, A64-encoded, added
in line to the HTML.
Now, there are obviously
pros and cons to
that, as we've discussed.
But it has a great advantage in
that we don't need to do so
much work on the client.
And also, once the first type of
device, like the first iPad
or the first PlayBook, has
rendered that article, we can
store it in the cache
for faster
performance in the future.
So my experience is mostly with
the Financial Times and
the Economist, which are very
much reading platforms.
So let's look at some of the
problems that newspapers and
magazines present on the web.
So the FT wanted a column
layout, which is obviously
inspired by their
print edition.
CSS columns is useful, but
it's not enough, even to
create a simple layout
like this.
This headline that spans column
one and two, you can't
do that with CSS columns.
You have the options to span all
of the columns or one of
the columns.
So we need to turn to JavaScript
straightaway.
And our first approach was to
iterate through every single
word in a paragraph, even in
an optimized way, find out
where to cut the paragraph, and
move the contents to the
next column.
You know that dealing with
text is really bad for
performance, so we looked
into other ways of
speeding this up.
And we developed
FT Columnflow.
This is Columnflow in action
on the Economist's app.
And actually, the FT, the page
before, was also running
Columnflow.
And if we look a bit closer at
what's happening here, we can
see the paragraphs highlighted
in red.
And you can see that the
paragraph at the bottom of
column one has been cloned
and moved to the
top of column two.
So yes, we have twice the
weight in the DOM.
But if we hide the overflow,
we get a nice result.
And it's actually much faster
than iterating through each
word in the paragraph.
So Columnflow has some other
features which really help
with responsive layout.
You can add classes on to the
flowed elements to stop
elements wrapping, so by
default, for example, it
doesn't wrap images.
You can also keep headings
attached to the paragraph
which follows them.
And you can position fixed
elements like headlines and
images on a particular page, a
particular column, spanning
any number of columns.
Columnflow will try and avoid
orphaned lines at the ends of
paragraphs.
So it would prefer two lines in
the next column rather than
one line on its own.
And it will try and determine
the vertical grid height and
add padding dynamically to
images and headlines so that
they conform to the grid, so
that you get a nice vertical
grid running through the page.
Columnflow does have
some side effects.
It's not perfect.
And one interesting one is
that fonts must be loaded
before it runs.
If a font loads after Columnflow
has laid out the
absolute position of each
paragraph, then you get into
big problems.
You can see here that there's
clipping at the bottom of
column one and at the
top of column two.
So in the Economist, we
actually use a font
pre-loader, which presents a
whole load of other problems.
Anyone who's looked into
determining precisely when a
font loads, it's a nightmare.
And there's a CSS3 fonts module,
which will hopefully,
in the future, add an
onload event or
something similar for fonts.
But not much browser support
yet, of course.
So taking it further, how
might we improve the
Economist's responsive layout?
I've hacked the code base
a little bit, added some
experimental enhance--
[AUDIO CUTS OUT]
GEORGE CRAWFORD: So this
article layout is
designed for the iPad.
And what that means is that
the number of columns is
hard-coded.
And even the aspect ratio of
the image is determined,
editorially, for the
iPad layout.
So when we launched on hardware
with a different
aspect ratio, the easiest
solution is to add white
gutters on the sides.
It's not a terrible solution,
but it's losing a little
element of that immersive
experience.
So why can't we add some
flexibility to this?
We don't need to hard-code
the number of columns.
We can determine the optimum
number of columns by thinking
about things like the
typographic measure.
So the measure is the number
of characters in a line.
And as the font size changes,
the number of characters you
can fit in a line will
also change.
So if we go for an ideal
typographic measure, then we
can also, based on the viewport,
determine the ideal
number of columns.
We can improve legibility
a bit by
modifying the line height.
So for longer lines of text,
it's a generally-accepted
principle that you want a bit
more space between lines, and
for shorter lines, a bit
less line height.
These are quite well-known print
concepts, but they're
only slowly coming to the web
as our devices provide more
and more immersive reading
experiences.
And also, there's some
technology that we're
waiting for, too.
We can vary the number of
columns that the image spans
based on the total number
of columns--
and also the width and also the
height of the viewport,
because we have to take the
aspect ratio into account.
So this is the first draft.
It's making better use of
the available space.
It's more immersive.
It feels like the app has been
tailor-made for your screen.
And it does increase
the legibility.
I'll just run through a range
of viewport sizes.
You can see some of the things
that we're changing.
So as the line length increases,
it goes too far for
the ideal measure, so we
add in extra columns.
And you can see the line height
changing slightly based
on the length of the lines.
And that image started off
spanning one column, then to
two, then to three.
So the same logic can be applied
to a static viewport,
but when the user is changing
the font size.
So as we increase the font size,
we have fewer characters
per line, so we actually
need fewer columns.
We can go even further,
improving the article's
typesetting.
We can learn from techniques
used to layout newspaper
columns like hyphenation
and justification.
So the default here is a ragged
right edge, which with
a narrow column gets a little
bit difficult to read.
But if you set justification,
it doesn't help [INAUDIBLE].
We get these large areas of
white space, and they can
sometimes form very
ugly rivers.
So we can add in hyphenation.
CSS Hyphenation, again, doesn't
have great browser
support, so I've used a
JavaScript library here.
And performance analysts
might worry about this.
It took 10 milliseconds to
hyphenate this entire article.
So I think it's worth
considering
for text-heavy layouts.
Now, we mentioned in the network
session earlier that
we might be able to do
more with images
and responsive workflows.
So maybe it's worth considering
on the editorial
side that they might even embed
metadata into image
files with a selection
of possible crops.
So you might be able to choose,
on the client side, a
range of aspect ratios.
Some may be a tighter
crop if the image is
going to be very small.
And then you can determine,
based on the size and the
aspect ratio of the space you
have, which would be the best
one of those crops to use.
So we can improve this layout by
maybe having a shorter and
wider image or having a tighter
crop that can just
occupy one column.
So what technology do we have
around for our disposal for
responsive layouts?
And what's coming up?
You've probably all seen grids
like this, the 960 Grid and
Twitter's Bootstrap.
These don't give a perfect
solution for
the responsive layout.
They're either completely fixed
width, or they only
adapt a little bit and then
instantly snap to a single
column on mobile devices.
So we've got some emerging
technologies which
will help us a lot.
In the Economist and the FT,
we're using Flexbox to help
with layouts, it's very powerful
and can be quite
complicated.
And then the CSS Grid Layout
module, which is only
currently in Internet Explorer,
is going to help a
lot with designing responsive
grid layouts.
And then Razvan's team at Adobe
are working on some
really nice proposals for
new CSS modules--
the CSS Regions and Pagination
templates for rich,
magazine-like layouts.
So I've devoted quite a lot of
time to Columnflow, but with
any luck, modules
like this will
eventually make it redundant.
Until we get browser support,
of course, we do need
JavaScript polyfills
to do the same job.
And then the CSS Exclusions,
allowing you to flow text
inside and outside shapes
and even images.
And we've got technology like
seamless iframes, web
components, the shadow DOM,
custom elements-- which, when
they're combined, might lead
to give us context-agnostic
encapsulated modules of HTML
and CSS which can adapt and
respond to their available space
rather than actually
worrying about the viewports
so much.
So we're looking into this
a lot for the FT web app,
creating individually-styled
modules which can be dropped
into any part of any
page without
interfering with other elements.
So hopefully that's given you
some ideas about responsive
layouts for magazines
and newspapers.
But what about the
other problems
that other sites have?
And how else do people deal
with responsive layouts?
I'll hand it back to Amber.
[APPLAUSE]
AMBER WEINBERG: All right.
So our first question is
actually going to be my
question, because it is a
problem that I have been
facing lately and I'm sure
many other devs have.
Kind of with the performance
talk as well, but is it worth
taking the performance hit and
extra time deving to serve up
retina images?
Or should we only pay attention
to retina images
when it's really important--
for things like icons or
photo-heavy websites?
Because a lot of sites don't
really matter as far
as the images go.
So George?
GEORGE CRAWFORD: Well, my
experience with the FT and the
Economist is that first of all,
it is a shock to see your
site on a retina display when
you haven't prepared for it.
It's really interesting, the
difference between a large
JPEG image, like the ones I
was showing, and the tiny
interface icons.
I think because we're so used to
really nice font rendering
and really nice PDF support,
just seeing a PNG, a tiny file
that could easily be doubled
without worrying too much
about the overhead, it really
makes a big difference.
And I think you can get away
with non-retina, large JPEGs.
And I think that's definitely
the first step.
And maybe then look into how
much overhead you're going to
add with large feature images.
But of course, some sites are
not using feature images to
the extent that we do.
ANDY HUME: Yeah, I think it
depends exactly what you're
trying to do on a given
site or a given page.
Clearly, a lot of the stuff
in the newspapers is about
high-resolution imagery, and
we have apps that are
specifically tailored to showing
those in engaging,
beautiful ways.
So those do need to be the
high-resolution stuff.
I think for the more Chrome
interface stuff, I'm sort of
in two minds.
I think as much as you can get
the browser to render this
stuff itself natively and get
away from images with some of
the visual stuff in CSS, making
sure you're using
rounded corners and drop
shadows as much as--
GEORGE CRAWFORD: And then icon
fonts and things like that.
ANDY HUME: Yeah.
And SVG to a degree as well.
And I think it depends.
Some icons, I'm not that
fussed about them
not looking as great.
I think things like the logo
is where you notice it, and
all other people notice
it as well.
GEORGE CRAWFORD: I've worked
with the Economist on getting
the articles to work offline,
and the number of stages you
go through where you add
size to the data.
So if we A64-encode our images
and then store them in Web SQL
or IndexedDB, which tends to be
A16-encoded, every time you
encode the image differently,
you're adding
massively to the overhead.
So if we then double the size
or quadruple the size of the
image file as well, this
is a big issue.
But as I say, I think interface
icons are really
important and other
things not so.
AMBER WEINBERG: OK.
So our own Andrew over here
asked an important question.
Is increased page weight an
inevitable side effect of
responsive web design versus
just a regular
separate mobile site?
RAZVAN CALIMAN: Yeah.
So if you talk about responsive
websites and you
look at images, for example, or
written images, there's no
clear-cut way of getting
around that.
Yes, you will have increased
file size with
the responsive website.
But then again, as Ilya and
other people mentioned
earlier, the overhead you have
afterwards is just some fishy
amount, some CSS.
And we're hoping to have the
extra markup you're using for
responsive layouts fixed in
proposals such as grid layout
or Flexbox.
Because that's mainly where
you're adding extra markup or
extra CSS to handle
various parts of
your responsive layout.
So in terms of adding size,
yes, I think right now
responsive websites do incur a
price penalty in file size if
you want to deal with different
size images, which
you should if you do care
about the performance on
different devices and
different browsers.
ANDY HUME: I think you've got to
be careful about taking it
to extremes, though.
Because you can start going down
a road where you end up
polyfilling things like
media queries in all
the versions of [? IE8, ?]
which there are libraries
to do that, and
they do it very well.
But I think that's kind
of missing the point.
If you have to add more and more
of these pieces of these
JavaScript libraries and
polyfills and the like to make
stuff responsive, I think you
will end up in a situation
where your responsive site's
mobile view, if you like, is
worse than it would have been if
you had just optimized for
mobile in the first place.
RAZVAN CALIMAN: Yeah.
I totally agree on this.
Of course you need to look at
the device, the context, and
where people are going
to use it.
Of course it doesn't make any
sense to polyfill for media
queries and the like.
So yeah, I do agree.
You find your lowest common
denominator, and you build up
from that, but you ensure you
give your users a good
experience.
The point is that I am in
favor of quite a lot of
polyfills right now, because
there's a lot of technology
that hasn't been tested quite
yet, and everybody's waiting
for it to come into browsers.
And polyfills give you a very
good opportunity to build the
technology experiment with it
and learn that some use cases
just don't fit--
like, see the AppCache model.
ANDY HUME: Or the Columnflow
stuff.
GEORGE CRAWFORD: I think at
every stage of the way we need
to bear in mind the good
user interface as well.
As soon as people get on to the
bandwagon of responsive
design and layout and
development, it's so easy to
add bells and whistles that
really aren't necessary or to
change the feature image for
each 50 pixel breakpoint as
the user resizes their browser
window and things like that.
And you have to really consider
how your users are
going to work through the site
and whether some of the
enhancements are really
necessary.
AMBER WEINBERG: Well, kind
of related to polyfills--
the newest CSS3 specs and stuff
are getting really,
really complicated in the
area of responsive
development and stuff.
And a user--
you, George--
asked, is it OK to continue to
push for more and more CSS
modules like Regions, Grid
Layout, et cetera?
Or is it actually
OK to just use
JavaScript solutions instead?
I kind of wonder that myself,
because CSS was known to be a
simple language--
easy to use, easy to learn.
And now it's becoming so
much more complicated.
GEORGE CRAWFORD: That's my point
totally-- that it's not
that I believe that we should do
these things in JavaScript.
Of course there are massive
performance gains to be had
from pushing things to GPUs and
all that kind of stuff.
But just looking at the average
CSS file now, it's
already complicated enough.
A lot of people who have
moved to Sass and other
preprocessors would agree that
we're pushing the limits of
what quite a simple syntax
can include.
And as soon as we get other
modules coming in, it just
gets more and more complex.
And maybe the question is-- is
CSS the right language or the
right technology to
deal with it?
RAZVAN CALIMAN: OK.
So first of all, that's
a very good question.
And I'd like to start
out with Hakim, the
guy that built Reveal.
He sent a tweet recently that
we're asking so much more of
HTML and CSS right now,
considering that it was meant
as a textiling declarative
markup language.
In response to your question,
I do think that we need to
push for more CSS module and
more support in the browser,
specifically on those areas
where JavaScript isn't really
supposed to be working at.
Like in terms of layout,
the browser itself
is doing the layout.
So I would much rather leave it
do the layout and focus my
JavaScript resources, which are
oh-so-scarce, on various
devices, given the complexity
of web applications, not
necessarily the complexity
of web design.
GEORGE CRAWFORD: We realize
that we're sort of almost
wasting time by trying to
optimize things like
Columnflow, because it's really,
as you say, a layout
technology.
And it feels counter-intuitive
to go over and over and over--
why isn't JavaScript perfect
for this job?
It's because it's not designed
for this job.
RAZVAN CALIMAN: It's not
designed for this job, but the
reality is that most CSS modules
don't really give you
the access you need
in JavaScript.
So up until now, there's
been a pretty much
all-or-nothing solution.
Is it all in CSS or
all in JavaScript?
And I really think that stuff
like CSS Regions--
it's intended to be a building
block, so it's not going to
solve your complete
problem in CSS.
But it gives you access via the
CSS object model, so you
can understand how your layout
has been rendered and your
various boxes.
And I think that's really
where CSS and JavaScript
should really work together--
in handing, for example,
layout and event handlers and
content flow differently.
GEORGE CRAWFORD: I was really
excited to hear, when I looked
into Regions, that, yeah, you
start off with CSS, but when
you run out of regions, when you
run out of flowed areas,
JavaScript gets involved,
right?
You have events, and you can
create new elements for
content to flow into.
And there's an
interoperability between the two.
RAZVAN CALIMAN: Yeah.
And at this point, this is
because CSS Regions is
supposed to be a building block,
and it doesn't handle
the complete refill
of the content.
And you go to use JavaScript to
listen to if your content
has fit in all of
those regions.
And that is seen as a limitation
by some people.
And to some extent they're
right, because you need some
sort of a method in CSS.
If you think about layout,
CSS should handle
the complete layout.
So right now the spec is
supposed to work really fine
with other specs like
Grid Layout.
But it's using empty
developments and it's using
the JavaScript just because we
don't have any other spec at
this point that will work.
What I personally would like
to see is some sort of
adoption of multiples to do
elements, so you can actually
define your complete
template in CSS.
Because basically, that's what
I want from my CSS, right?
I want it to easily swap out
templates, easily flow out
content, and leave the markup
to handle just the semantics
and describing my actual
content, right?
ANDY HUME: Do you think part
of the complexity at the
moment is that there are a
number of emerging new CSS
layout modules, and it's not
necessarily clear until we've
started playing around with them
and experimenting which
ones are going to be good for
what type of problems?
So for example, the Regions
stuff is enabling lots of very
new kinds of layouts that
haven't been possible at all
before, really, without things
like Columnflow, too, and
Exclusions in the certain column
and things like that.
Whereas Grid seems to me to be
more about helping us do the
kind of layouts we've been doing
for a while but in a
simpler way, a way that's more
suited to a real layout system
rather than sort of hacking
floats and positionings.
GEORGE CRAWFORD: Sure.
And something the browser can
optimize as well, the
performance of it.
Yeah.
AMBER WEINBERG: All right.
So would it be useful to have
native CSS media queries at
the element component
widget level and
not just the viewport?
And that is related
to our other
question about page weight.
Would that help?
ANDY HUME: From my point of
view, that would be a very
nice thing to be able to do.
That's not something you can
abstract into a system and
have work at the moment
for various reasons.
But it's desirable.
And maybe there's something
around--
George mentioned web components
and being able to
codify behavior for a particular
type of interface
element and deal with those kind
of exceptions that might
arise on a sort of case-by-case
basis.
GEORGE CRAWFORD: I think this
modular idea is really
interesting, where in the
JavaScript world, we're
leaning more and more towards
modularized code, which is
good development practice
anyway.
The work I mentioned that we
were doing is mostly being
done by Wilson over there
on the FT's web app.
And he's sort of almost faking
the shadow DOM and custom
elements before it's arrived
by using media queries to
write before and after
pseudo-elements with content
on individual modules in the
page, and then in JavaScript
reading those tags.
So for example, for a certain
module, you might--
with a before or after
pseudo-element, you might
write the words "column" or
"row." And then the module now
knows that it should behave
as a column or a row.
So that's starting to
fake the media query
on a modular level.
And who knows what's
coming up?
But the problem, of course, is
that we also always need to
wait for the browsers to catch
up with what we need and that
the spec writers need to wait
to hear what we want.
But I think this kind of modular
layout is really
interesting.
AMBER WEINBERG: Do you think
that interrupts the idea that
the content should be exactly
the same on the desktop and
mobile that we're kind of
following right now, if we are
able to swap out different
things
for different viewports?
GEORGE CRAWFORD: So this is
another question that I put in
the Moderator is I think we
probably all come up against
on our mobile devices sites that
are basically truncated
in terms of their usability
until you get to the bottom of
the page and you click
the link that says
View Desktop Site.
And then you can actually
use some functionality.
This gets really,
really boring.
And it's going back to the UI
and the content providers.
Is designing for mobile simply
cutting out 30% of the useful
information on the page?
No, of course it's not.
ANDY HUME: I think at some point
in the past, there's
been a desire to try
and second guess
what people call context.
Why are you using the sites
on a mobile device?
Oh, it's because you're walking
down the street and
you want the phone number
of the restaurant
you're going to.
But whether that was ever true
or not is kind of irrelevant,
because it's certainly
not true now.
And deriving some kind
of context, I don't
know how that works.
I'm not sure that you can.
GEORGE CRAWFORD: It was
immediately interesting for me
to hear a proposal that, on
the server, for the first
request, we might know the
viewport dimensions and not
have to do user agent
sniffing.
But actually, as was pointed
out, you can't tell very much
about a device just from
the viewport dimension.
You certainly can't tell
the conditions in
which it's being viewed.
So you don't know whether they
want a huge word displayed on
the screen with the answer to
their question, or whether
they want a 5,000-word article
to read, because you can't
predict that kind
of information.
So we need to give
them flexibility.
But I think having a View
Desktop Site link at the
bottom of the page is
not the answer.
RAZVAN CALIMAN: Yeah.
In terms of using web
components, I'm actually quite
excited about this.
Because when you think about
your content, it's not
necessarily only to give it to
your users in full in mobile
versus on desktop.
You also have to think
about the context.
And if you swap out and you
don't think about content like
text content, you think about
web application controls,
they're different on the
interaction mode on a mobile
device rather than on
a desktop device.
And to answer the question if
media queries are OK inside of
web components or small,
isolated elements, I think
that's really important and
useful, because it gives you
the flexibility of reusing
most of your elements.
GEORGE CRAWFORD: It's not just
that they're isolated from
each other but also that they
can be dropped into other
projects, right?
ANDY HUME: Isolated from
the layout from
the particular page.
MALE SPEAKER: So this is a great
discussion, but I think
that media queries
on other elements
is the wrong approach--
in part because if you look at
how the browsers today treat
media queries, they don't work
too well when the page is
being constructed.
We don't have access
to the viewport.
We don't evaluate the rules.
Like if you look at your rule
right now, if you look at the
webkit, it says, hey, this looks
complicated in the sense
that it's not [? screened, ?]
which means that we're
just going to
download the resource.
And this is a fundamental
trade off.
We don't know the viewport
information when we're
constructing this page.
So this is not the
right mechanism.
Right now, if you declare a
bunch of CSS [INAUDIBLE],
we'll download them all.
So having this information
on elements is not the
right way to do it.
What we're talking about here
is service-side adaptation.
So I think the premise that we
need some way to exclude
certain chunks of functionality
is right.
I think media queries is
the wrong way to do it.
ANDY HUME: Yeah.
I don't think we're necessarily
saying media
queries is the right
technology.
In fact, media queries at the
moment, they make us fixate on
the viewport.
Because in terms of measuring
the width of something, that's
the only thing we have.
And it's actually not
very interesting
that you can do that.
You can do some interesting
things with it, and that's why
responsive design now has
a name and everyone's
talking about it.
But I think, yeah, it's more
granular than that.
The context which you want to
respond to from a layout point
of view is more granular
than just the viewport.
And yeah, whatever you guys
think is the right way to let
us do these kind of things,
I'll go with that.
AMBER WEINBERG: So are there any
front-end alternatives to
responsive web design that can
fulfill the promise of being
device-agnostic?
Or could there be?
ANDY HUME: Java.
RAZVAN CALIMAN: I don't
know what you mean by
device-agnostic.
If you look at the web as we
see it right now, yes.
HTML, CSS, that fulfills the
job of making something
responsive.
But if you look only just a bit
ahead of what devices are
coming and what device-agnostic
means for
Google Glass, for example--
does responsive web design work
for your contact lens?
I think we need to think
about that technology.
And that's maybe a space where
native will actually win.
Because the web as we see it
right now, it works really OK
for one-dimensional,
two-dimensional layout.
What happens in three
dimensions?
I don't have a clear-cut
answer to that.
So whatever we're doing right
now, it's optimized for touch.
It's optimized for pointing,
different screen sizes.
But whenever you change the
screen sizing, whenever you
change the interaction model
from touching to speaking, for
example, does the web offer
the same flexibility to
building responsive?
What do you guys think?
ANDY HUME: I guess it depends
how you define the
scope of the web.
Is it any client technology
ever?
What defines the web?
Is it the open nature of it?
Or is it the--
GEORGE CRAWFORD: Yeah, I
think you've said it.
RAZVAN CALIMAN: The
answer is no.
There isn't a catch-all
technology right now.
AMBER WEINBERG: Right.
So should the browser be more
chatty about its environment,
which we spoke about
in another session?
Should we know what the
viewport size is, what
connection it is,
their bandwidth?
GEORGE CRAWFORD: From the work
I've been doing, step one is
just, well, give us the right
information and ideally, give
it in a unified way
across browsers.
That would really, really
help, right?
When a device incorrectly just
announces its pixel ratio or
something like that, it
basically means you either
added another seven lines of
hack or you have to not query
that information.
And I find that more
frustrating, I think, than not
knowing some things about
the environment.
I think we've probably covered
network and bandwidth and
things like that.
But I think if what we're trying
to do is to provide as
immersive an experience as
native apps, then yeah, we do
need to know a lot about
the device that is
displaying the app.
But--
ANDY HUME: Do we need to
know about that on
the server as well?
GEORGE CRAWFORD: I think
it would help.
I think if I'm working really
hard to store as many issues
of the Economist offline on
someone's device, I know I've
only got 50 meg and that that's
actually 25, because
it's all A16-encoded.
And I would really like to be
able to optimize my images and
to package things up and
effectively do what a native
iOS app is going to do, which is
sort of prepare everything
in advance and ship it.
And then you can cache the hell
out of that, and you get
a really, really good
experience.
You do run into issues where,
if you're running a
JavaScript-heavy site, you
have to, we've already
mentioned, like Mustache
templates on
the server and client.
You even have to start preparing
articles and
additions using Node on the
server, because you have to
use the same logic that you're
using on the client.
But maybe that's fine.
I do understand that any changes
to HTTP are enormous.
And adding one line to a header
is going to massively
affect web traffic as a whole.
But I think in return, we can
stop wasting bandwidth by
delivering totally
useless images.
ANDY HUME: And people are
still doing user agent
detection on the server to--
GEORGE CRAWFORD: Sure,
as was said in an--
ANDY HUME: [INAUDIBLE] --device
into mobile, tablet,
or desktop or whatever.
GEORGE CRAWFORD: As we said in
an earlier session, we're
doing it already.
So test to see which approach
is fastest.
And please, browser vendors,
either don't declare a
property or declare it correctly
or let us know that
it's buggy.
But it really, really makes our
life a lot harder when you
give the wrong information.
RAZVAN CALIMAN: Just one
point to add to this.
It does actually happen on
server-side right now.
And it's particularly useful for
digital publications when
you want to target a whole
slew of devices.
So even though it's not
responsive in the responsive
sense that it happens on the
client side and it reacts to
anything, there's a lot of
versions of the same
publication rendered
server-side.
And you just go there, and
your device is just the
terminal, and it receives
the end result.
And right now that works
pretty fine because
everything is stored.
Everything is controlled.
Ideally, you would want to give
this to the end user,
because you can't really
simulate all of the user
agent's font rendering--
does it have or doesn't it have
hyphenation, stuff like that.
So it's happening right now,
and I think we should move
away from that.
But we need to wait for browser
vendors to catch up on
the technologies we actually
need like decent layout, grid
template, Flexbox, all of that,
because we're actually
hacking right now with those.
So up until we get these HTML
and CSS improvements, we're
going to see a lot more digital
publications which are
just images at this
point because
they're simple to render.
And yes, that's a 700 megabyte
magazine, but it will work
across all of your devices,
because they're pre-rendered
for each screen size.
GEORGE CRAWFORD: But do you
agree in principle that it's
an advantage if you know at
least a little information
about the viewport dimensions,
for example, on the server,
and that you accept that there's
going to be a bit of
downscaling of images?
But rather than enormous to
very small, you can ship a
medium-sized image at the very
least, because you know
something about the viewport
dimensions on the server?
RAZVAN CALIMAN: Definitely.
I agree we need that kind of
information, but you need to
be responsible in
how you use it.
For example, we had an
example earlier--
knowing the bandwidth and the
bandwidth being wrong, you
might assume something wrong
about the device and give it a
bad user experience or a very
good user experience.
But the device cannot
download it.
So yeah, I do agree you need
that kind of information
server-side.
As a developer, you need to use
it and not make too many
assumptions about the device.
GEORGE CRAWFORD: It's
interesting, then, Ilya's
points on media queries that
that's actually responsible
for so much of what we discuss
when it comes to responsive
layout, right?
And the reason we're obsessed
with viewport dimensions is
because that's the one thing
we have on the client to--
well, one of the chief
things we have in
CSS to control behavior.
So it's got a lot to answer
for in a way.
AMBER WEINBERG: Well,
let's move on to the
flip side of the coin.
With all this new stuff that
we have to take into
consideration, what about the
arguments that responsive web
design isn't worth it at all
and that there is merit to
just having normal
zoom-and-swipe sites?
Considering that's
originally--
when Steve Jobs came on stage,
he touted you could have the
full web on your phone.
ANDY HUME: I guess people want
to create designs that fit
that device.
And if you look at what people
create for the iPhone natively
and the iPad natively, it's not
double-tap to zoom in on a
column and swipe around.
And I think that's what's
driving what we want to do
with web technology, is the
stuff that's happening native,
to try and create more engaging
experiences, to coin a phrase.
GEORGE CRAWFORD: We've struggled
to define what a web
app really is sometimes.
But one possible definition is
to do with how immersive it is
and whether you feel
your app has been
designed for your screen.
And if you see the whole of the
BBC News front page on a
screen that size, it's
fantastically easy to get to
the-- if you know the layout of
the page, you don't need to
read the words.
You know that the link you're
looking for is in the
bottom-right of the page.
It's super quick to get to that
content, but it doesn't
feel so immersive.
But then maybe we go too far the
other way that you get a
beautiful layout with
a full-sized image.
And you know you can swipe
through 12 images, and it's a
satisfying experience.
But where the hell are the
links to find my content?
And we really have to take
both kinds of directions
before we find the answer.
We were talking earlier about
pagination and what the
solution is for presenting
text-heavy sites and visual
media-heavy sites in
terms of pages.
Do we want the content
to scroll?
Do we want it to be
split into pages?
And I think this
kind of thing--
the third option maybe is to
present everything at once and
then to have a tap-to-zoom
kind of paradigm.
It really depends
on the content.
The point I made was, for the FT
and the Economist, I think
pagination's really useful.
Because if you are distracted or
look away for some reason,
everyone knows how
to read a book.
We all know that if you look
away and you look back to the
book, you have a rough idea that
you were halfway down the
right-hand column.
But when you're looking at a
single-scrolling column of
text, it's sometimes
very hard.
And I find that I have to
concentrate more on the
mechanics of what I'm doing
when I'm scrolling.
And just to simply tap
or swipe to go to the
next page is great.
But then you made the point
that this is not at all
appropriate for some
other sites.
RAZVAN CALIMAN: Yeah.
We need to take into
consideration media-rich
digital publications.
And you want to do it in a
paginated responsive view.
You easily find that you're
going to lose context between
the text and illustrations or
pictures the text is referring
to if you want to embrace
responsiveness.
And cutting off an image
at the middle page is
not really an option.
And if you do move the image
or the illustration to a
different page, you end up with
a lot of white space on
your pages, which you can't
really control.
And you have to understand
that a lot of digital
publications are coming
from print.
And that's where designers are
used to having a lot of
control over where content goes,
where text is on the
same page with the
illustration.
And the trade off when you take
on responsive web design
with paginated view is that
you lose a lot of that
fine-grain control over where
your content is heading.
So I am actually keen to
understand even more how
people see pagination as an
advantage on the web when we
are accustomed to the paradigm
of scrolling or tapping.
And where it makes sense, for
example, in text-heavy
articles, like you mentioned,
that's a very valid point.
But does it make sense
for anything else?
AMBER WEINBERG: So should
responsive web design, then,
emulate print?
On a 27-inch screen, is having
six columns go all the way
down and all the way across
going to be easy to read?
RAZVAN CALIMAN: I think
web design should
emulate a bit of print.
And that's something the
Exclusions spec is doing.
And that's something
specifically that should be in
CSS, because JavaScript is not
really meant to do something
like that, flowing text inside
of shapes or around shapes.
GEORGE CRAWFORD: And typography
as well, like the
hyphenation and stuff.
It would be great to have good
support for that, right?
RAZVAN CALIMAN: In terms of
moving the complete idea of
print to digital, I think
that's the wrong idea.
You don't really get anything
with six columns of text.
You don't get more information
out of that page.
You have to understand that
print has evolved like that
into multi-column layout and
having multiple articles on
the same page because of the
physical constraints of the
page, something we don't
have on the web.
You can actually use the device
size to your advantage.
And if you do have a large
screen size, that doesn't mean
you have to put in more columns
because you have space.
There's the point that
George made.
What's the distance between
the user and the device?
Are you reading that on a TV?
Six columns is not
going to help.
You're going to need larger type
and something optimized
for your laying back on the
couch and reading the content.
GEORGE CRAWFORD: Any graphic
designer will draw your
attention to the whole concept
of white space, that that
really helps.
Maybe I was wrong with my slide
going from the white
gutters on the side to filling
all the available space.
Because it's quite an assault,
visually, to deal with that
kind of thing.
And white space is incredibly
important.
So for sure, the answer is no,
we don't want to fill a
27-inch monitor with columns.
But we need to really learn a
lot from print and then adopt
it to our own.
ANDY HUME: Yeah, I think it's
natural that we look at things
like print or what's been in
the past to kind of inform
what we're trying to
do in a new medium.
But the reality is it
is a new medium, and
it's still quite young.
And these things, as we learn
by adopting bits of print--
and some stuff does work,
some stuff doesn't--
we'll learn more about the
medium that we're actually
working in.
That's assuming it doesn't
move so fast that lessons
we've learned one week aren't
relevant the next, when you
consider we're now talking about
TVs and the distance
from the screen and things.
AMBER WEINBERG: OK.
So kind of on the same layout
issue, Oliver asked-- current
responsive web design solutions
to grid systems make
for very complicated
presentational HTML.
Defining the same behaviors with
CSS, on the other hand,
is very tricky.
So what needs to be
the middleman?
Is that still JavaScript?
Or is there going to
be something else?
ANDY HUME: So I'm not sure
that there is a middleman
available at the moment.
I think I understand what he's
saying when he says there's
lots of presentational
class names in HTML.
And I think at the current
point in time, that's the
solution you should
move towards.
As I said, I find being able to
have a layout system that
is abstracted from everything
else, a grid system, and then
implement it in markup easily
is very valuable for all the
reasons we've talked about--
making sure components
are extracted
from layouts and pages.
And at the moment, the easiest
and simplest, most
maintainable way of doing that,
in my view, is with more
presentational class names.
What we have coming in the
future that I think will help
this is the Grid
Layout module.
AMBER WEINBERG: Is that it?
OK.
So we just have a couple
of minutes left.
I have one more question
for you.
Very quickly, if you could have
one thing, anything in
responsive web design approved
by the spec or majorly
implemented in any browsers,
what would your
dream feature be?
RAZVAN CALIMAN: Overnight
grid layout templates.
GEORGE CRAWFORD: I think,
because of my work on
Columnflow, I think Regions.
Maybe I'm not so clear on how
they all interlink, but the
demos I've seen of Regions
just look great.
I've spent a long time flowing
text into areas.
And just to have something
that will do that
for me would be great.
ANDY HUME: I'm inclined to
agree with grids mainly
because I get just as excited
about new stuff that's going
to make my life easier rather
than new, shiny stuff.
And also media queries at a
component level, however that
might be implemented.
And call it media queries.
AMBER WEINBERG: Well, I would
like something for retina,
something easy.
All right.
Well, that is it for the
responsive panel.
And thank you, guys.
[APPLAUSE]